Bitte schön.
Okay.
Okay, ich bin Dr. Issa Alton, ich bin der Dienstabende Arzt und ich möchte gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmigesprach führen.
Ist das in Ordnung so für Sie?
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Ja, okay.
Wenn Sie nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, geben Sie mir einen Bescheid und mache ich eine Pause, um Ihre Fragen zu beantworten.
Ich werde Ihnen zunächst eine wichtige persönliche Frage stellen und zu Ihrem Beschwerden übergehen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, okay.
Okay, eine weitere Frage.
Wie heißt du Siebite?
Mein Name ist Benjamin Pfeiffer.
Herr Pfeiffer, könntest du Siebite i-ren namen Langsam Ustawiren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Benjamin, B-E-N-J-A-M-I-N.
I?
Und der Familienname ist Pfeiffer P-F-E-I-Double-F-E-R.
D-F-E-R.
Pfeiffer.
E-R-Sch.
Herr Pfeiffer, könnten Sie mir Ihre Gebustatem verraten?
Ja, ich bin am 14.09.87 geboren.
47.89?
87.
87, ja.
Sind Sie 36 Jahre alt?
Okay, okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
92 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
84.
Okay.
Und Herr Pfeiffer, was führt Sie so mir?
Was kann ich mit tun?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche starken Schwerzen seit 2 Tagen in meinem rechten Unterschenkel.
Und zwar, ja, also, das ist auch angespollen,
das rechte Bein und die Haut ist ganz rot und glänzend
und es fühlt sich so spannend an, so ein Spannungsgefühl da drin.
Und ja, das hat vor 2 Tagen langsam angefangen.
2 Tagen.
Richtig.
Nur rechte Seite oder 2.
Ja, nur das rechte Bein, ja.
Okay.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen in anderen Pöpentalen aus?
Fuse oder Oberkirchen?
Ja, also, das geht so bis in die Kniekehle hoch.
Kniekehle.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt oder?
Was ist passiert?
Nein, Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein, aber ich war lange mit dem Auto unterwegs.
Ich hatte, es war ja warm und ich war mit dem Wagen unterwegs
und es war ein Staus auf der Straße.
Es waren ja Feiertage jetzt und ja, war es schrecklich voll
und es ging überhaupt nicht vorwärts
und ich habe dann, ja, ich habe letztendlich 7 Stunden
mehr oder weniger ununterwochen im Auto gesessen
und ja, dazu habe ich mir auch noch eine Erkältung eingefangen.
Also meine Nase läuft die ganze Zeit
und ich habe auch so ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen.
Ich glaube, ich habe die Klimaanlage ein bisschen zu stark eingestellt,
weil das so unendlich warm war
und so näher ich mit dem Staus da auf der Autobahn.
Okay, okay.
Kopfschmerzen hat die
Kopfschmerzen gleichzeitig begonnen oder?
Ja, das war so ein, ja, also am Tag nach dieser Reise, ja.
Okay, und Verstoppung Nase.
Haben Sie auch Fieber?
Weiß ich nicht, ich habe nicht gemessen,
aber also heute Nacht habe ich, habe ich sehr stark geschwitzt.
Sehr stark geschwitzt.
Okay.
Ich fühle mich auch so ein bisschen krank, also
so das Essen schmeckt nicht und eigentlich möchte ich nur was trinken
und ja, ich fühle mich insgesamt nicht gut.
Okay.
Und könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen,
die Wadenschmerzen genau beschreiben,
ist er dumpf, so nehmend, stark oder was würden Sie sagen?
Also, das ist ein Drück in der Schmerz.
Drückend bis, ja, wie kann man das beschreiben?
Ja, Drückend bis Stechen, sage ich mal.
Okay.
Und Wichtag sind die Schmerzen, auf einer Schmerzkala vorbei,
ein sehr lecker Schmerzen und sehr, sehr stark Schmerzen,
sind sehr stark Schmerzen.
Wo würden Sie einordnen für...
Zehn sind sehr stark Schmerzen, sagen Sie.
Ja, also ich kann das ja aushalten.
Ja, also vielleicht so bei fünf oder so.
Fünf.
Ja, insbesondere wenn ich, also wenn ich das nicht bewege,
wenn ich rumlaufe, ist es ein bisschen schlechter.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Faktöre für diese Schmerzen,
Ausdosefaktöre für die Schmerzen,
dass die Schmerzen verbessernt oder verschlimmert?
Also wenn ich das Bein ein bisschen hoch lege,
habe ich das Gefühl, ist es ein bisschen besser.
Besser.
Ja, aber wenn ich rumlaufe, merke ich auch,
das tut schon sehr weh.
Und deswegen laufe ich halt nicht viel rum.
Ich versuche möglichst gar nicht aufzutreten mit dem Bein.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Angeschulden, Rote und Glänze.
Rote und glänzende Haut, ja, genau.
Haben Sie auch Geschirr oder Wunde bemerkt oder nicht?
Wunde ist da nicht, nein, nein.
Hatten Sie schon einige Beschwerden für Herr Gehab
oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern an solche Geschichten.
Ich habe schon längere Zeit so ein bisschen krampf,
aber ich habe halt einen Steeberuf.
Und ja, da habe ich schon manchmal so schwere Beine.
Aber jetzt solche Schmerzen wie jetzt
und dass das eine Bein so dick wird,
das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Und Kopche Merchan, haben Sie früher so was erlebt oder?
Naja, ich habe eigentlich chronisch so Nebenhöhlenentzündungen.
Das habe ich schon seit vielen Jahren.
Wenn ich eine Erkältung habe,
dass mir das immer gleich auf die Kieferhöhlen schlägt
und dass ich dann so ein bisschen brauche,
bis das wieder rauskommt, alles.
Okay.
Ich habe dann so ein Medikament.
Das nehme ich dann, das hilft mir meistens ganz gut.
Das sind so Gelomethulkapseln.
Das kann man in der Apotheke frei kaufen.
Und da habe ich immer das Gefühl,
dass ich dann das schneller los werde.
Okay.
Haben Sie diesmal diese Tablet eingenommen oder?
Ja, ich habe jetzt angefangen damit,
weil ich gemerkt habe, dass die Beschwerden eben wiederkommen.
Ich habe das immer zu Hause eigentlich.
Okay.
Und haben Sie gegen Wadenschmerzen eine Schmerzmittel eingenommen oder?
Nein, da habe ich mich gar nicht getraut,
irgendwas zu nehmen,
weil ich erst mal beobachten wollte, was da überhaupt los ist.
Okay.
Und Herr Pfeiffer,
haben Sie schon einige
Wadenschmerzen gehabt,
vor allem beim Gehen oder bei Belastung oder nicht?
Also solche Schmerzen kenne ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß, dass ich so ein bisschen Kampf daran habe,
weil ich eben den ganzen Tag auf den Beinen bin.
Manchmal arbeite ich halt im Verkauf.
Und wenn ich dann den ganzen Tag gestanden habe,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass die Beine schon mal ein bisschen geschwollen sind.
Und dann hilft mir das schon,
wenn ich die ein bisschen hochlege oder mal abdusche im Sommer gerade.
Aber wie gesagt, dass ein Bein so angeschwollen und so stramm ist,
das kenne ich überhaupt nicht.
Okay.
Sind früher, ich meine früher Schmerzen,
sind die Schmerzen stärker beim Standen als Laufen?
Beim Stehen, meinen Sie.
Okay.
Oder was meinen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Wann hat es?
Ja, also jetzt stehe ich, ich versuche ja nicht zu stehen.
Und auch wenn es möglich ist, wenig zu laufen, weil es halt weh tut.
Okay.
So, haben Sie Atemnot oder Schwerlucht?
Nein, nein, Atemnot.
Also abgesehen von dem Schnupfen jetzt,
aber sonst habe ich keine Atemnoten.
Nein.
Okay.
So, wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Pfeiffer?
Also normalerweise ist der ganz gut, aber jetzt die letzten Tage,
was sage ich ja schon, will es mir nicht so richtig schmecken.
Okay, okay.
Und haben Sie im Laufe derzeit Ab- oder Zutennomen?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, also ich glaube nicht.
Nicht?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Sturrgang?
Also jetzt, also keine neuen Beschwerden.
Mit dem Sturrgang, ja, da muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich habe eine bekannte Glutenunverträglichkeit
und da reagiere ich halt mit Durchfall und mit Magenschmerzen.
Und wenn ich da aber also gut aufpasse
und keine glutenhaltigen Nahrungsmittel esse,
dann komme ich eigentlich gut zurecht.
Ja, wenn ich natürlich unterwegs bin, ist das manchmal ein bisschen schwierig
und dann kann das schon mal passieren, dass ich eben nicht so gesund esse
und dann kriege ich auch Prompest-Schwerden.
Okay, okay.
Und, Herr, spüren Sie, dass Ihr Herz schlage
oder haben Sie Herzstopp halt bemerkt?
Also mein Herz schlägt, ja, das hoffe ich doch zumindest, ja.
Aber es schlägt nicht mehr als sonst, würde ich sagen.
Und Herz stolpern, also das ist nicht auffällig, mein Herz.
Ist mir nichts zu aufgefallen.
Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Also normal kann ich gut schlafen, wenn ich nicht gerade verschnupft bin
oder auch jetzt, heute Nacht habe ich halt geschwitzt, das sage ich ja.
Und wenn man nachts schwitzt, dann wacht man natürlich irgendwann auf,
muss da ein Schlafanzug ausziehen und trockene Sachen anziehen,
dann ist der Nachtschlaf natürlich gestört.
Okay.
Sie haben wegen der Schwitze nicht geschlafen, richtig?
Nicht so gut geschlafen, ja, ich bin halt aufgewacht,
weil ich verschwitzt bei ja.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie leiden an Krampfadern,
leiden Sie an bestimmte chronische Erkrankungen,
ich meine Diabetesblutzucker oder Bluthochdruck oder ...
Ja, also wie gesagt, diese Glutenunverträglichkeit,
das ist eine Sache, die ich halt beachten muss.
Und dann hat man bei mir vor fünf Jahren festgestellt,
eben eine Schilddrösenerkrankung und das ist eine Hashimoto-Erkrankung.
Und deswegen muss ich halt regelmäßig ein Schilddrösenmedikament nehmen,
dann nehme ich jeden Morgen eine Ultrorox-Tablette.
Ultrorox.
Okay. Wissen Sie, wie stark ist?
Wie viel Milligramm? Also ja, das sind hundert.
Hundert.
Ultrorox 100.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Milligramm oder Einheiten oder was auch immer sind.
Ja, okay.
Und gibt es noch andere Krönchen?
Ja, also das ist mehr als genug, würde ich sagen.
Ja, was ich gesagt habe, diese Nebenhöhengeschichte,
das ist mehr oder weniger auch so eine chronische Geschichte,
dass das eben immer wieder kommt, das ist so eine Schwachstelle.
Ja, seit wann leiden Sie an chronische,
oder, ich bin so ein Süddl?
Ja, das ist schon, ja, also ich würde sagen,
das ist schon mehr als fünf Jahre, vielleicht so sechs, sieben Jahre.
Und das war alles, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, also liebe Güte, das ist ja mehr als genug.
Ich bin ja noch jung, also ich finde es ist schon schlimm genug,
dass ich so viele Krankheiten habe.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Krankfaden leiden.
Wann wurde festgestellt?
Ach ja, das hat mein Hausarzt mal so im Rahmen von so einer Untersuchung,
hat er halt gesagt, ja Mensch, Sie haben aber ganz schöne Kampfalern
und da habe ich gesagt, naja gut, kein Wunder, ich stehe ja auch den ganzen Tag
und ja, aber wir haben da noch nichts dagegen gemacht,
also das ist noch nicht optimiert worden oder so.
Wann wurde festgestellt?
Ja, das ist auch so vier, fünf Jahre her.
Fünf Jahre.
Sie haben gesagt, keine Operation, aber wie würden Sie behandelt?
Wie würden Sie behandelt?
Ja, das habe ich noch gesagt.
Stimmkosse oder Medikament?
Nein, ich habe Ihnen noch gesagt, wenn ich abends einen langen Arbeitstag hatte,
dann lege ich die Füße halt hoch und wenn es warm ist,
dann brauche ich die Beine halt ab und dann ist das schon ein bisschen besser.
Okay, sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen, nein, tatsächlich habe ich noch nie eine Operation gehabt, nein.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Glutenunfertigkeit
und sind bei Ihnen ein bisschen schnell.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen gegen eine bestimmte Medikamente oder Kontrastmittel aller die bekannt?
Ja, tatsächlich darf ich kein Novalginen bekommen.
Da kriege ich so heftigen Ausschlag davon, das habe ich nicht vertragen.
Okay, und so rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche jetzt seit fünf Jahren gar nicht mehr.
Davor?
Davor habe ich mal, ja, zehn Jahre lang habe ich mal ein bisschen geraucht,
aber nie so richtig viel, wenn man nur so eine halbe Packung am Tag, also nicht wirklich exzessiv geraucht.
Trink ins Regelmäßigalkor?
Ja, das kann man sagen, doch, also ein Glas Wein am Abend, das trinke ich ziemlich regelmäßig an.
Okay, bitte nennen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Hatten Sie oder haben Sie schon mit dem Drogen konsumiert?
Drogen konsumiert, ja, also klar, früher haben wir immer mal wieder ein bisschen haschisch geraucht, so ein Däund.
Und jetzt ist es ja auch legal, aber jetzt mache ich das eigentlich nicht mehr.
Aber als ich jung war, haben wir das schon so bei Partys oder so gemacht am Abend, ja, da haben wir schon mal ein bisschen was geraucht.
Okay, okay.
So, sind Sie Verkaufs, richtig?
Ja, also ich bin selbstständig, ich habe das Geschäft von meinen Eltern übernommen
und bin da aber im Verkauf selber auch tätig.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ein Kinder habe ich ja.
Ein Kinder.
Ist er oder Sie gesund?
Das Kind ist gesund, ja, ja.
Okay.
Mit wem wollen Sie?
Wir drei wohnen zusammen, meine Frau und mein Kind und ich.
Okay.
Und ich habe nur ein paar Fragen über Ihre Eltern.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Über meine Eltern?
Ja, doch ja, die leben beide noch.
Haben Sie eine chronische Erprobung oder sind Sie gesund?
Ja, also meine Mutter ist relativ gesund, die hat ein bisschen Kniegelenksprobleme,
aber sonst ist sie eigentlich so viel, ich weiß, ganz gesund.
Und mein Vater ja, der hatte jetzt vor drei Monaten eine Darmooperation,
dann Krebs festgestellt und der hat leider einen künstlichen Ausgang dann gebraucht,
aber wir hoffen, dass der irgendwann auch wieder zurückgelegt werden kann.
Also jetzt hat er das erst mal ganz gut überstanden.
Okay, okay.
Und Ihre Mutter wurde Sie operiert oder?
Bisher noch nicht, nein, Sie hatten nur Probleme damit.
Okay.
Lassen Sie Ihre Kollegen beherrende Fragen stellen, das reicht.
Haben die Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, Frau Pfeffer, hatten Sie schon einmal
Trauma oder Operation für Ihre Beine?
Nein, also Trauma hat er schon gefragt und operiert worden bin ich auch nicht, nein.
Da ist zum Glück noch da.
Okay.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt, fragiert.
Deswegen, Kollegen, noch Fragen, ich weiß nicht.
Hat schon jemand eine Frage?
Ja, ja, bitte.
Herr Pfeffer, in der letzten Zeit sind Sie in der Wald oder auf dem Wiese gewesen
oder haben Sie einen Picnic gemacht?
Nein, also wir waren nur am Strand, aber nicht im Wald oder in der Wiese
und Picnic hatten wir auch nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wir waren nur am Strand und dann eben diese lange Autofahrt.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bisher.
Gerne.
Fühlen Sie sich der Haut ein bisschen wärmer als rechter Bein?
Wärmer als linke Bein?
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Ich habe das, ja, so spontan bin ich da nicht drauf gekommen,
aber ich glaube, das fühlt sich wärmer.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Taubhausgefühl, Muskelkräfte oder?
Ah ja, nee, hat der eigentlich nicht, nee.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich habe angegeben, dass ich nachts geschwitzt habe.
Insofern kann das sein, müsste man überprüfen.
Haben Sie Schwindel?
Schwindel ist mir nicht, nein.
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 gebt?
Ach ja, natürlich, ja, dadurch, dass ich sehr, sehr viel Kundenkontakt habe,
habe ich mich seinerzeit komplett impfen lassen.
Ich habe also vier Empfungen bekommen.
Danke.
Stimmt, darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, ja.
Lisa, können wir anfangen?
Ja, das kann man.
Okay, schönen guten Tag, sehr verehrte Frau Oberarstein.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen
und ich möchte mit Ihnen besprechen
und ich möchte den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, der Patient heißt Benjamin Pfeiffer.
Er ist 36 Jahre alt und 82 kg schwer.
Ein Meter 84.
Bitte?
29.
Machen wir nachher, Doktor, machen wir nachher.
Okay.
Und ein Meter 84 cm groß.
Herr Pfeiffer stellte sich bei uns
wegen seit zwei Tagen
ein Herd auf den Rett,
einen Schmerz,
einen Zufall.
Er hat gesagt, dass die Schmerzen
Die Kniekehle oder die Populität ausgestrahlen wurden.
Ausstrahlen würden?
Ja und so den Patienten zufolge sein Dichtsmersen bei Hochleggerung BESA geworden.
Der Patient Schmerz-Indl.Stadt liegt bei 5 von SIN auf einer Schmerz-Kala.
Und als begleitet septome sein ihm die folgende Bekante.
Er hat eine Spannungsgefühl und eine gerötete und glänzende Haut.
Im betroffenen Bereich.
Und die vegetative Anamnese seit einer Auffälligkeit besonders hinselig hyperhydros seit 2 Tagen.
Er sei bis schon nie operiert worden.
An Vorerkrankungen leide an chronischen Synesitis seit 6-7 Jahren.
Und Hashimoto Trudit seit 5 Jahren.
Und Varikos auch 5 Jahre.
Er wurde die folgende Medikamente regelmäßig eingenommen.
Er hat 100 mg Morgans und Glimolkapsel bei Bedarf.
Wie heißen die?
Bibi-Tas.
Was für Kapseln?
Glimolkapsel.
Und er sei nicht rauch, aber davor 5 Paket Jahre.
Und er trinkt Glas Wein pro Tag.
Und er habe mit Jugend Mariana probiert.
Mariana hat kein Hegevon.
Kann er bis oder?
Ja, aber keine Hegevon.
Er habe Gouluten und Verträglichkeit oder Gouluten-Antropatie.
Und er habe auch Neulagen, die Allergie aus der Zeit mit erzielen.
Und er sei selbstständig verkaufen.
Er sei verheiratet.
Er habe einen Kind.
Einen Kind?
Er ist mit seiner Familie Susam.
Und seine Mutter hat einen Kind.
Und ein Vater...
Ja, ein Tachbücher.
Er ist ein Arthros oder?
Ja, wo?
Konarthros, ne?
Konarthros.
Ja, Konarthros.
Und ein Vater leidet an Kolonkarsinon.
Er wurde operiert und fernung.
Er fernung darm operiert, oda Kulestektomi.
Er hat sich eine Kolostomi untersogen.
Und aufgrund der geschilderten Zepthome des Patienten
gehe ich von Pferdach auf TVT aus.
Und die Differenzielldiagnostische kommen.
Varikos.
Varikosis, ne?
Varikosis, was noch?
Selulitis, oder Erisipel in Betracht.
Ja, wobei Selulitis, das ist irgendwie...
Das ist bei uns nicht so richtig ein Begriff der...
Tromboflebitis.
Gut. Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ja, ich warte Körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, bei der Körperliche Untersuchung überprüfe ich Puls und Schwellung.
Welche Pulse überprüfen Sie?
Ja, Arteriativialis, Dorsalisperis, Posterior.
Und dann Schwellung, Flawium, Haarausfall, Nagell in Pils.
Ah, okay. Als denkbare Erisipel.
Interessant.
Ich überprüfe eine Wunde.
Es gibt ein paar klassische Trombosezeichen.
Ja, ich weiß.
Payer, Payermeer und Hormansseichen.
Sehr gut. Ja, alles klar.
Also, dann sind Sie schon ein Stückchen näher, was die Trombosediagnostik angeht.
Was machen Sie sonst noch?
Und dann Laboruntersuchung, kleine Blutzbild, CRP, D-Dema.
Und dann so Bissige, dann es kann auch Glucose und Hemoglobin A1C.
Und dann...
Was vielleicht interessant sein könnte, wäre die Gerennung.
Ja.
Okay, gut. Und was machen Sie weiter diagnostisch?
Ja, werde Farbdopplerzono-Grafie oder Doppel-Zonografie oder Ultrashalk veranlasst.
Dann... ja.
Gut, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose tatsächlich bestätigt, wie wäre dann die Therapie?
Wenn der Doppel-Zonografie hat?
Ja, ich...
Bei Bestätigung unserer Verdachtdiagnose würde ich Schmerzadaptierte Therapie und Trompose und dann...
Beide Beine gleich?
Wie bitte?
Trompose?
Würden Sie Trompose sagen, gleich beide Beine?
Beide Beine, ja.
Sie leitet an Varecosa und natürlich Heparin und Fragzone-Heparin.
Dann...
ASS...
ASS?
Ja.
Wenn Sie das Heparin absetzen, oder was?
Wie bitte?
Wie lange kriegt der Heparin?
Ja, ich würde 5.000 Einnahmen verabbreiten.
Verabreichen?
Ja.
Wenn ich als Proflaktische ASS einsetzen würde, dann...
Kein Markumar?
Markumar, ja.
Markumar, oder neue...
Ja, Xavélso...
Antikvagulane, Hütschaban, oder Ribaxaban, ja.
Wie lange sollen die das nehmen?
Ich würde sagen, 2 Monate, oder?
6 Monate.
Bei Trompose eigentlich 6 Monate.
Und...
Was macht man, bevor man die Markumarisierung und auch den Strumpf dann wieder absetzt?
Was ist da erforderlich?
Ja, so...
Vorsch...
Einnahme...
Komadin würde ich...
frax...
fraxionär Heparin einsetzen.
Und dann...
Ja klar, das ist klar.
Ist das Markumar oder das Quarellto sein Wirkratter?
Ne, die Frage ist, wenn Sie das absetzen, das Markumar, nach 6 Monaten,
was ist dann erforderlich?
Erfordeli?
So...
Wir...
Zolten...
Rekurrent Trompose, die Patient der Patient schützen
und gegen Lungelembole...
Ja, worum es mir geht, bevor der seinen Markumar absetzt,
muss man eine duplexsonographische Kontrolle machen.
Also gucken, ob die Trompose wirklich weg ist.
Ja, so.
Nächste Punkt. Klar, einmal akut den Patienten aufklären
über Risiko einer Lungenartigenembole.
Nach dem Motto, wenn Sie merken, dass Sie schlecht Luft kriegen,
kommen Sie sofort wieder hierher.
Ja.
Das ist diese Geschichte.
Und zum anderen, dann, wenn der Patient
seinen Kompressionsstrumpf wieder los ist,
beziehungsweise die Markumarisierung beendet wird,
was sollte er auf alle Fälle dann weiter machen?
Weiter machen.
Wenn er länger Auto fährt, wenn er eine Flugreise macht,
wenn er den ganzen Tag im Laden steht,
wenn er zur Messe geht, was soll er dann machen?
Ja, er soll bewegung,
oder regelmäßig Sporttreibung,
oder regelmäßig bewegung machen,
oder bewegung, dann sie sollten,
sie sollten, ja, sollten nicht lange Reise,
oder lange Sitzung.
Aber wenn er die Reise machen muss,
was soll er dann tun,
wenn er eine lange Flugreise,
oder wenn er eine lange Busreise macht,
was macht er dann?
Er kann einfach eine Kursepause machen
und dann er kann fünf, sieben Minuten bewegen.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen rumlaufen, oder wie?
Ja.
Was muss er machen?
Er muss erstens seine Kompressionsstrumpfe anziehen
und zum zweiten kann er profilaktisch Heparin kriegen.
Das muss er natürlich auch,
wenn er immobilisiert wird durch irgendeine Krankheit,
wenn er sich jetzt in Fuß spricht,
oder was, was ich beim Skilaufen,
die gräten irgendwie das Knie ausrengt
und er muss länger Zeit liegen,
dann musste er halt eine gute Profilaxe haben.
Weil er schon mal eine TV-TV hatte,
das musste er halt immer angeben.
Jut, ja.
Okay.
Ja, ich darf gleich zur Manöverkritik übergehen.
Wir haben ein bisschen Sprach- und Verständigung-Probleme gehabt.
Haben Sie gemerkt?
Ja.
Doch, Gönnlis hat schon reklamiert,
er wiegt nicht 82 Kilo, sondern er wiegt 92 Kilo.
Also die Zahlen sehr genau aufpassen.
Die Geburtstaton war aber richtig
und wo auch alles richtig war,
wie lange er welche Krankheit hatte.
Eine Sache ist mir gleich am Anfang aufgefallen.
Habe ich schon sehr, sehr oft gesagt,
Sie kündigen an, ich stelle Ihnen einige persönliche Fragen.
Oha, Hilfe!
Eine persönliche Frage ist eine private Frage.
Und ich möchte vielleicht nicht jemanden,
den ich gerade eben fünf Minuten kenne.
Ich möchte keine persönlichen Fragen beantworten,
sondern es geht ja um Fragen zur Person.
Ja, so, das ist was anderes.
Fragen zur Person, klar, muss ich hier abklären,
sind Sie Herr Pfeiffer, stimmt das Geburtstaton?
Ja, sind Sie versichert bei der sowieso Krankenkasse?
Das haben Sie ja im Zweifelsfall,
wenn Sie in der Klinik arbeiten,
auf dem Aufkleber oder auf der Karte.
Ja, so, gut, also nicht persönliche Fragen zur Person.
Dann, ja, was man gemerkt hat,
Sie haben das sehr intensiv genügt,
diesen Anamnese-Satz,
stellt sich vor, wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehender
oder wegen vor zwei Tagen zuerst aufgetretener
zunehmender Schmerzen im rechten Unterschenkel.
Was Sie da nicht beschrieben haben, eigentlich, der Oberärztin,
das waren die subjektiv geschilderten Sachen, Rötung, Schwellung,
meine ich, habe ich nicht gehört.
Erdutörmal.
Ach doch, stimmt, ja, kam später, genau, kam später, genau, sorry.
Und wo ich nicht ganz sicher bin, ob Sie gesagt haben,
dass die Beschwerden aufgetreten sind nach einer langen Autofahrt.
Ausreden nicht geschildert.
Eben, genau.
Und das wäre ja nun relativ zielführend,
ja, wäre also schon wichtig, diese Information weiterzugeben.
Gut, die Kopfschmerzen,
die sieht der Patient selber ja eher in Zusammenhang
mit seiner Sinusitis und hat er ja selber auch
eine Erklärung für gegeben.
Es war warm im Auto, Klimaanlage.
Und, ja, gut, Medikamente war auch klar.
Ja, die Formulierung ist mir aufgefallen.
Klar hat der Patient jetzt das angegeben,
dass er als Jugendlicher haschisch geraucht hat.
Sie haben gesagt, mit Jugend, in der Jugend,
oder als Jugendlicher, ja.
Als Jugendlicher hat er haschisch oder Marjorana geraucht.
Heute spielt das keine Rolle mehr, kann man so sagen.
Was ich vermisst habe bei der Glutenunverträglichkeit,
dass Sie da den Begriff der Zoliakie bringen.
Das wäre noch...
Am besten ist Gultensensitivität.
Jetzt höre ich nichts mehr, weil es hier anfing zu regnen.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Ambestin ist gluten sensitivity.
Gluten sensitivity.
Neue Fache und Griff hier. Gluten sensitivity.
Aber sagt man nicht zölierkisch?
Nein, nicht zölierkisch. Gluten sensitivity, Entropatik.
Aber zölierkisch ist ein bisschen anders.
Ah, okay.
Von einem Kollegen kam der Hinweis jedenfalls auch.
Ja, also gut.
Ja, Dr. Gündis hat schon reklamiert,
Sie haben ziemlich lange gebraucht für die Anamnese.
Der Bericht ging eigentlich ziemlich zügig.
Muss man jetzt auch dazu sagen,
dass das ja nicht so eine sehr umfangreiche Geschichte war.
Eigentlich ist es ja schnell erklärt.
Und natürlich waren Sie sicher in der Diagnostik
und in den Untersuchungsmethoden.
Da gab es überhaupt keine Probleme.
Okay, ich würde sagen,
für heute haben wir es geschafft.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Dr. Alter?
1.21.June.
Ah, noch vier Wochen Zeit.
Heute ist der 21.June.